the commuter headache unfolding in one
of America's most contested city
congested cities San Francisco's
brand-new trans Bay Transit Center will
be closed for three more weeks after
cracks were found in the building
support beams as John Blackstone reports
it's the latest problem for the transit
hub that's been billed as the Grand
Central Station
of the West San Francisco sleek new 2.2
billion dollar bus terminal just six
weeks after its high-profile
ribbon-cutting is out of service
displacing 35,000 daily commuters it's I
think fortunate that the whole thing
didn't collapse including the bus tech
points that serious the whole thing it's
a serious problem to have a major beam
like that crack the building was closed
after workers found cracks and two
80-foot long steel beams structural
engineer Joe Murphy is not involved in
the project this is the point of maximum
demand on the beam
the troubled terminal here has an
equally troubled neighbor just next door
the millennium tower now-famous says San
Francisco's Leaning Tower this 645 foot
tall luxury condominium project is
tilting about 14 inches to the northwest
and sinking about 18 inches since it
opened in 2009 both buildings are on
land that was once underwater part of
San Francisco Bay but is now being
developed with soaring high-rises for
now the sagging terminal is being held
up by huge jacks closing a major street
adding to rush-hour frustration a
possible contributing cause of the
cracked beams may be one of the
buildings distinctive features it's five
acre rooftop park spanning three city
blocks so the beam has the weight of the
rooftop garden on top of it and then it
has this column that's helping support
the bus deck this is a lot heavier than
a standard roof absolutely yeah several
times heavier than a standard roof by
next Friday engineers expect to send two
cracked sections to a lab for testing I
can assure you we don't know whether
it's a design issue whether it's a
fabrication issue or it's an
installation issue even before this the
terminal was already controversial
costing 800 million dollars more the
originally expected and now closed for
weeks or possibly months as engineers
try to figure out how to make it safe
for CBS this morning Saturday John
Blackstone San Francisco that image is
not very comforting some yeah what a
mess natural thing you need in San
Francisco is more traffic yeah more
trouble